When I started doing Slim's hair this morning,
I realized that we were all out of hair gel,
and when I brought it up to lucky,
he said he would take care of it,
so he started making us some hair gel.
He started by pouring about three cups of water into a pot
and then bringing it to a boil.
Once the water hit a rolling boil,
he pulled it off the stove
and added three tablespoons of flax seeds to our water,
then brought this back to a boil on the stove,
giving it a really good mix.
And once it became frothy and thick in consistency,
he strained it through a fine mesh strainer.
Once that mixture was in the bowl,
he added some essential oils that would stimulate the scalp,
like mint and Rosemary. He did about five drops each,
made sure that was all incorporated
before transferring it over to a glass jar.
After it was cool enough to use,
he decided to take over doing Slim's hair.
So he scooped some of that gel out
and applied it to his already wet hair.
He worked all the way from the roots through the ends
and then let his hair air dry
and it left his curls looking really defined.